ROBERT KUBIS: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
"From Blobs to Tables,
Where to Store Your
Data," then stay tuned
because here is the Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With all the choices available,
choosing the right storage
or database system for your
existing or new applications
can be hard.
In their talk, Dave
Nettleton and Robert Saxby
walk you through
Google's cloud offerings
and help you make decisions
for the right storage servers
to use for your use cases.
Starting with a
short retrospective
on how storing of bits and
bytes evolved over time,
Dave explains key
features of each product
from Cloud Memorystore
to Cloud Filestore.
Driven by different
workload requirements,
each product is used
in different ways
in various industries.
So no matter if you
are building games
and need a fast
managed dictionary
with Cloud Memorystore for SAP
millisecond key value lookups,
or if you're running
your SAS platform
in retail and e-commerce
and need a fully managed
relational database
with Cloud SQL.
And when your business
happens to grow like there's
no tomorrow, you'll need
a horizontally scalable
relational database.
But no worry.
We have you covered
here with Cloud Spanner.
Of course, not all applications
require slick schemas
and relational semantics.
Many times flexibility is
more important to move fast
and innovate.
Our scalable document
database Cloud Firestore
has you covered here.
With integration into
Firebase platform,
you can build your next highly
scalable mobile application
which synchronizes data across
multiple devices for millions
of concurrent users seamlessly.
Now to make your applications
better behind the scenes,
understanding how your
products are used is key.
Cloud Bigtable with
its reads and writes
and single-digit
millisecond range
and age-based
compatibility will help
you drive your real-time
analytics to new levels.
And if you need a massively
scalable pay-per-use OLAP data
warehouse that speaks SQL
and can create petabytes
of data in minutes,
then BigQuery
will be your best friend.
But let's not forget, your
videos, music, images,
or for that matter
any kind of blobs,
all those go into planet
scale plop storage cloud
storage where you can optimize
for cost and access frequency
without changing APIs.
To store bits and bytes
closer to your VMs,
we offer persistent disks
in various shapes and sizes,
spinning or solid
state, flexibly attached
to your virtual machines or
even closer next word processors
with local SSDs.
We're almost there.
There is one more storage
solution fresh from the press.
If you need fast file access
from multiple machines,
for example distributed jobs
through a managed network
file system up to 64
terabytes and 30k re-dialups,
then check out our newly
added family member
Cloud Filestore Yes,
Cloud Filestore.
The L is important here.
In Toronto at the
session, Robert Saxby
talks about best practices and
common architecture patterns
for data storage and analytics.
In short, separate your
compute and storage and you'll
do great.
If this sparked your interest,
please watch the full talk.
Links are in description below.
Don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube channel
for more create
Next Rewind content.
Thank you for watching.